alles schief gelaufen und jetzt gaben
dafür mega
weil sich objekt gesehen vollzogen sie
das ist komplizierter politischer
prozess
eine stadt in aufruhr kulturplatz über
die museums krise in basel
[Musik]
basel ist die stadt der museen
doch inzwischen des basel noch etwas
ganz anderes sie statt der museums
misere willkommen bei kulturplatz
smi
unterfinanzierte museum prekäre fehler
in der organisation und baufällige
gebäude als rumort heftig in der basler
museumslandschaft
letztes jahr hat sogar der ansonsten so
kulturfreund hier grosse rat die
reißleine gezogen und einen
entscheidungs stopp gefordert
jetzt gerät das zuständige
präsidialdepartement unter beschuss wie
konnte es so weit kommen und wie kann
der ruf der museumsstadt basel gerettet
werden diesen fragen gehen wir heute
nach
[Musik]
das naturhistorische museum in basel ist
eines der ältesten museumsgebäude der
schweiz und es ist sanierungsbedürftig
die beiden direktoren zeigen uns dass
170 jährige haus das bis unters dach mit
objekten gefüllt ist
doch das geht jetzt nicht mehr
dann relativ früh entdeckt dass es ein
vorteil dass ich alles stimme ist
schaffen so etwas gedacht
und noch was darin ferne aber das ist
einfach genutzt wird
[Musik]
undichte dächer kaputte heizungen keine
ideale bedingungen für museale objekte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der gang über als objekt kann immer
kein klima wird ihnen ganz jetzt
geschehen wird weiß objekt co
die sind von schimmel zogen sie und das
prinzip dass mehr korrigiert an wo über
400 jahre alt sind die sammlung kaputt
können
das naturhistorische museum braucht mehr
platz
der bergbau wie das museum nach seinem
erbauer genannt wird entspricht nicht
mehr modernsten museums bedingungen eine
totalsanierung ist unumgänglich
vorsah paradiesvögel 8 millionen objekte
müssten für einige jahre aus ziehen denn
unterirdisch geht es im museum nochmals
vier stockwerke tiefer mit depots voll
von skeletten eingelegten tieren und
insekten
schrift die spende des mittelmeerraums
dunkelhaarig und giftig aber du bist
schon eine spinne ist es für android
die frage lautet hier das museum nach
der sanierung hierher zurück in ein
gebäude das heute schon aus allen nähten
platzt das wurden die beiden direktoren
verhindern haben das ist gefragt wenn
man ihnen bleibt hatte waren wir die
ersten die musiker aber das ist eine
option sei der prozess braucht zum sagen
das ist jetzt blockiert
die beiden direktoren planen einen
neubau und zwar nicht im zentrum wie
heute sondern an der peripherie dafür
einiges größer und gut erschlossen
kostenpunkt 220 millionen franken
das ist viel geld doch es sei
unumgänglich sagen die beiden chefs
aber der zeitpunkt ist schlecht gewählt
denn es rumort in der basler kultur und
museumspolitik alle fünf staatlichen
museen hatten in den letzten jahren
finanzlöcher personalabbau oder großen
sanierungsbedarf
[Musik]
die politik kommt kaum nach die löcher
zu stopfen
und ein ende ist nicht in sicht was
passiert in der vorzeigestadt der museen
basel hat fünf staatliche museen die
museumsdirektoren entscheiden
selbständig über finanzen inhalt und
personal
doch sie sind zu 100 prozent dem
präsidialdepartement unterstellt dass
die aufsicht hat
gerät ein museum in schieflage liegt das
in der verantwortung des
präsidialdepartements in den letzten
jahren sind unter anderem das
historische und das kunstmuseum in
finanznot gehört
es lag an der politik die finanzlöcher
zu stopfen und zusatzkredite zu
bewilligen
es bleibt die frage wie kam es dazu
tobit schäfer war bis vor kurzem
präsident der
geschäftsprüfungskommission des grossen
rates
er untersuchte 2015 die ersten basler
museen in finanznot unter anderem das
historische museum
ich sehe die ganze finanzierung und wo
das es möglich dass man bücher ist als
aufdruck scobel sich beliebig erhöhen
wenn man gleichzeitig ohne dass das
nochmal irgendwo angelegt auf die imame
sitte von drittmitteln budgetiert für
die versorger können von unterwegs sind
was hätten dann zudem defizit führen
[Musik]
nachlässige personalführung und
fehlplanung bei sonderausstellungen
führten zu einem defizit das
präsidialdepartement griff erst ein als
es schon zu spät war
als die direktorin entlassen wurde war
das stiftungsvermögen weg und es blieb
ein finanzloch von rund 800000 franken
vielleicht im fca klaren partner gaz
positiv formulieren das nicht würde
basieren aber um schluss hatten die
wellenfront ob sie und dass ich alle
haben an dieser front wurde dabei sehr
mit dem museums gesetz wurde nicht sehr
klar ist wo man sehr genau analysiere
zum logischen weg verantworten
das fazit der
geschäftsprüfungskommission ungenügende
steuerung und kontrolle der museen das
präsidialdepartement führe die museen
nicht gemäß der gesetzgebung die antwort
des ehemaligen leiters der abteilung
kultur dem die museen damals unter
standen die system habe funktioniert
immer wie sie genutzt wird und selbst
stand ich im rückblick mit allen
informationen würden sagen gehörten
früher reagieren immer ein anderer
bereich aber das ist faktum immer sehr
einfach zu sagen das historische museum
war nur eines von vielen das saniert
werden musste für schäfer ist klar es
besteht reformbedarf beim
präsidialdepartement bis heute elisabeth
auch sie sind sie knapp zwei jahre
regierungspräsidentin und vorsteherin
vom präsidialdepartement mir redet über
die desolate situation vor der pause
musste er für die museumslandschaft wie
hat sowie trainer
also ich möchte ein vehement widersprach
museumslandschaft in basel ist überhaupt
nicht immer die salate zustand mit dem
kunstmuseum größte problem kam und die
können wir hätten jetzt wollen wenn sie
im budget prozess setzte sollte gold im
groß rot geplant ist sind noch nicht
behoben das muss man zu werke
die hand fürs münster haben ihre
betriebsanalyse denn sofort gestartet
sie haben wo eigentlich die finanzielle
problem sind und erschrocken historische
museum und mehr als zwei millionen
theater etwas kunstschuss regierung und
das ist jetzt ein großer road wird im
dezember budgetdebatte denn besprochen
man hat ihrem appartement in der
vergangenheit verletzung von der
aufsichtspflicht vorgeworfen strategie
lose gerade den gpk bericht von 2010
vorgegangen einige fehler gemacht
singende flüssige finden die lösung sind
was genau es gibt längere begleitung von
der abteilung kultur
foto museum geführt worden
und das funktioniert so erfolgt dh der
grund roland museumsdirektorin katja von
skoda ist ein etwas mit unbedingt passen
also sie wehre sich eigentlich nicht
sagen will es natürlich dass sicherheit
und sie die europartner handlich und
besprechen was zuständige sie möchten
machen und dabei wie die finanzielle
situation ist haben das
präsidialdepartement ist der richtige
ort und museumsdirektoren kontrollieren
hat sie überhaupt mittel dazu das könne
leisten
das ist eine große aufgabe es ist ein
großer fortschritt ich glaube sie sind
richtig im präsidialdepartement
natürlich jeder abteilung kultur casino
2016 war das große jahr des
erweiterungsbaus des kunstmuseums basel
die stadt zahlte 50 millionen für einen
neubau weitere 50 millionen offerierte
die roche erbin und mäzenin maja oeri in
rekordzeit der hielt basel-stadt eine
museums perle fast geschenkt
mit fanfare eröffnete man den neubau es
war der letzte große akt des scheidenden
direktors bernhard mendes bürgi und ein
meilenstein für die abteilung kultur der
stadt basel
[Musik]
alle wollten diesen baum die beamten die
museumsverantwortlichen und auch
patricia von falkenstein die für die
liberaldemokratische partei im grossen
rat sitzt und mit entschieden hat große
rote oder sich kein problem und es rund
den job gut und alle in große rot und
präsidial dementi hat ein neubau wolle
sich aber riesig ist ganz toll sind
passiv dass die privat
so waren sie in die kultur und andere
institutionen unterstützen
denn wie gesagt ja jetzt nciht mehr
bauamtes und hansjörg seine zustimmung
mit folgen denn die prognosen für den
betrieb des kunstmuseums entsprachen
nicht der realität
die ehemalige vize direktorin lüner
zimmer rechnete im kulturplatz damals
vor
wir haben eine leichte erhöhung der
staatlichen mittel und wir werden auch
wie bisher erwirtschaften wir sehr viel
mittel durch eintritte und führungen und
verkäufe auch das wird steigen wir haben
das eigentlich gut ausgerechnet
nur knapp ein jahr nach der eröffnung
wurde aber klar dem kunstmuseum basel
fehlt es massiv an geld der neue
direktor josef helfenstein schlug
ziemlich schnell alarm
was für mehr wichtigste ist dass seo
analyse geheilt langform in ried wo
gleitet das museum braucht bestimmt die
bestimmte betriebs kredit und da um zu
helfen die staffel holte sie und das ist
der relativ klar wurde dass da
handlungsbedarf
gut also kompliziert der politische
prozess oder größten größe kredit da da
ich für gladbach und eine höhere
steinbruch zusätzlich verhandlungen
und da der zweite schritt ist gemacht
wurde
hatte man die betriebskosten runter
gespielt obwohl man davon wusste das
fass zum überlaufen brachte dann die
betriebsanalyse eines wirtschaftsprüfers
der ertrag aus den eintritten und den
shop verkäufen lagen weit unter den
prognosen
und beim neubau war man personell massiv
unter druck irrt das erweiterte museum
das sich zu den fünf besten der welt
zählt hatte eine organisation die
anscheinend keiner normalen prüfung
stand hielt nein es ist nicht sauer
sondern es hätte totale wechsel kam das
ist nicht nur einen wechsel vor einer
für die gruppe zunächst sonnensystem ist
das neues museum das museum hat sich
quasi verdoppelt es ist schwierig sie
und mitarbeiter so marathon hin aber das
gute ist mithin sofort also fortgesetzt
gerade die förderung des kunstmuseums 2
millionen franken jährlich mehr für die
betriebskosten die politiker reiben sich
die augen
das betriebsanalyse macht einen schnitt
geben zeigt das thema alles mit
funktioniert hat monat könne
funktionieren und quintessenz ist all
das nicht dass man das die
verantwortlichen benannt und dort
entsprechend konsequenzen wird sie mit
verantwortlicher spanien das ist alles
schief gelaufen und jetzt geben dafür
mehr gehalt
[Musik]
doch das präsidialdepartement schiebt
auch da die verantwortung von sich
der damalige amtsvorsteher die moral war
inzwischen abgetretenen sein kulturchef
philipp bischof wurde zum neuen direktor
der pro helvetia
jetzt lag es an der nachfolgerin
elisabeth akkermann die scherben
zusammenzukehren
das museum braucht dringend neue
führungsstruktur hat zu wenig personal
und ist unterfinanziert was ist ihre
reaktion sie was sie da bricht zum
ersten gehört also ich befragte dass sie
dann bricht ganz genau zeigt wurde lich
wo handlungsbedarf besteht und wo
wirklich eine finanzielle mittel mehr
gesprochen werden also dass das genau
aufzeigt wurde nicht wieder eröffnet vom
neubau dezimierte bietet habe es damals
gesagt mir persönlich sehr genau
berechnet dann ist der neue direktor und
alles ist anders weil ich anders sollte
im betrieb no und gesehen dass das
mittel ist wenig betriebsmittel sind für
rossi über die seat ibiza ab jetzt
geht's um zwei millionen plus wo braucht
während wo das kunstmuseum seit ausbruch
der betrieb aufrechterhalten
das ist ein gebiet im 17
und wirklich mit mit wenig mitteln
eigentlichen ganz hervorragend die
leistung braucht und man muss jetzt
ruhig dass das besser aufgestellt wird
das personal wird das ist mir sehr
wichtig als départements vorsteherin sie
haben es angesprochen
es wird der betriebsanalyse gefallen
muss er einen anderen die wir ziemlich
sicher zeigen was wir könnten mal sagen
also vom tisch
pauli museum hat mich kalt wie können
sie das politisch zu bringen das ist
einfach wichtig dass kalt und musikräume
dass das mit dem leistungsauftrag ist
also mit der leistung erbringen dass das
im einklang steht
vor dem museum
[Musik]
marc fielmann ist der neue direktor des
historischen museums
er hat den ruf eines querdenkers und
innovativen fun racers als er anfing war
er überrascht vom zustand des maroden
museums als erstes verfügte er einen
ausstellungs stopp personal mit wenig
kapazität von der auftrags- oder füllen
dann ist das platzproblem dass mir
einfach depot hand 5 cents und tritt so
dass man sie wieder dort mit markante
profil positionieren will das profil der
knorrige letzten paar jahren mitglied
resources in basel rennt
das historische museum hat neben der
barfüßerkirche zwei weitere standorte
das eine ist das haus zum kirschgarten
einwohner aus dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert es muss dringend saniert
werden
hinzu kommen acht volle depots überall
in der stadt verteilt
ich muss mich selber orientieren
hier kommt man kaum nach mit
inventarisieren geschweige denn
sachgerecht lagern für polizeiliche
richtlinie nimmt in die halte daran
unsere waffe karabiner
lohfelden
letztes jahr an einer pressekonferenz
wies fielmann vor seiner chefin der
neuen leiterin abteilung kultur auf die
maroden strukturen des museums hin
es kam zum offenen konflikt konflikte
großes wort konflikt würdig sagte hammer
aber mir haben diskussionen natürlich
und das ist auch richtig und gut so wie
das die und am schluss dass auch als
parcours notiert sind sicher er weiß die
type also klatsche im charakter mit den
gern am fuß tragen aber am schluss war
bei dieser ziel erwähnt dass sie mich
los in basel gut geht und damit licht
für die keine flächen
die politik hatte aber gar keine freude
mehr und war inzwischen in einen streik
getreten
keine weiteren entscheide zu den museen
bevor eine strategie vorliegt
[Musik]
als die neugewählte vorsteherin des
präsidialdepartements elisabeth
akkermann das papier dann präsentiert
wird darin vor allem am status quo
festgehalten
alle fünf museen haben im gleichen maß
ihre berechtigung
einzige veränderung langfristige budgets
und engmaschigere kontrolle eine vision
für die zukunft sieht anders aus
papierstau allgemeinplatz nicht wirklich
was war denn jetzt genau und gut 35 auf
heute und ebene möglichst viel freiheit
gab sich wir nicht es ist wenig später a
und b kombiniert kombiniert wird das ist
bewegung nicht nur museums peter sollten
sich bruckner allee bisschen vermisst
auch luca us-präsident der fdp hatte
mehr erwartet museums strategie muss es
mit sich trug beantworten wo dem
schwerpunkt setzen wo die jetzt ein
leuchtturm museum uns uns leichter woche
dauern sprachen darauf kosten bedeutet
aber dass noch der andere sind da völlig
bei den anderen museen andere kultur
bereichert nicht die entsprechenden
mittel kann soll investieren und genau
hier prioritäten setze ich die hat eine
besondere strategie gewünscht
prioritäten wären angebracht denn macht
man weiter wie bis anhin dann wird das
sehr teuer
er hält das naturhistorische museum
einen neubau dann zieht es für 220
millionen an die peripherie zusammen mit
dem staatsarchiv der alte standort im
zentrum muss dringend saniert werden
damit neu das antikenmuseum einziehen
kann
kostenpunkt rund 120 millionen fremden
eine erneuerung braucht auch das
historische museum das haus zum
kirschgarten soll für 35 millionen
franken renoviert werden und wer meint
mit dem neubau sei das kunstmuseum aus
dem schneider
er täuscht sich auch der altbau braucht
ein facelifting für weitere 100
millionen in den nächsten zehn jahren
stehen in basel museums um broten für
rund eine halbe milliarde franken an
wäre es nicht sinnvoll prioritäten zu
setzen um auch erste von einer halbe
milliarde frauenquote kommenden jahr
brauchen man glaube ich dass das
politisch konto
wir haben wir sind tatsächlich inneren
phase wo die alte museumswärter wenn
saniert werden und zum glück kann man im
moment auch die finanziellen mittel dazu
und ich glaube das ist ganz normal dass
man halt immer ein gewisser abstand muss
saniert
das ist aber noch nicht klar dass sie
die finanziellen mittel wertet haben das
gemeindekonto sturz und ich glaube wenn
soll und das sanieren wenn nicht jetzt
das naturhistorische museum wird ein
neubau will mehr platz als und räumt
auch ein messe ag situation wo alle
museen in boston den kompromiss hin und
sagen müssen ihre liebe galt das
natürlich machen es ist aber sehr
schlechte lösung
berechnet sie brauchte teil wenn sie
würde den ball wiederum erstens muss
sanieren so oder so er hat das was
betriebsschlosser mindestens wenn nicht
fünf jahre war das museum zu und
betriebskosten erhöht sogar
wahrscheinlich als sieben darüber und
dass ich einfach keine gute option
was machen sie wenn jetzt der neubau
ablehnen
das naturhistorische natürlich für das
naturhistorische museum wie viele museen
braucht es und wie groß müssen sie sein
diese fragen muss man sich in basel
stellen denn auch wenn das kunstmuseum
die führung ausbaut und zwei millionen
mehr erhalten sollte es wird nicht das
ende des wachstums seien mit jeder
vergrößerung fließt mehr geld ins
personal und in die infrastruktur
geld das dann für ausstellungen fehlt
dem wachstum das ist völlig dass ich
große frage kommt oder irgendwann wird
es geht nicht an großes wachstum oder
das gibt es nicht aber die museen nicht
und darum wer trotz aller diskussionen
wir mit dem kann ich halt gebietes lager
also das addiert diskussion das ist dass
er schwierige diskussion wie wäre es
wenn man häuser zusammenlegen würde ein
ausstellungshaus für mehrere museen
man könnte an infrastruktur sparen und
sich mehr auf inhalte konzentrieren
für marc fehlmann im historischen museum
hieße das auf einen der drei standorte
zu verzichten weniger fixe kosten dafür
mehr geld für die bewirtschaftung der
sammlung und wieder vermehrt
ausstellungen
das würde heißen dass man endlich das
eintritt angeklebt die objekte halls
head mit den relikten der erste song
ineinander standort zusammen ich wieder
ins bewirtschafter ein schlosskonzert
rungen dass der politische auftrag aber
ich glaube was mit dem museum regeln und
das bedeutet halten auf leichtfertige
entscheidungen treffen
schwerpunkt sei im moment nicht so
buckel hat
wir sind im quartier st johann hier soll
der neubau des naturhistorischen museums
hinkommen was in thüringen hat große
pläne für sein museum offene depots um
den besuchern neben den ausstellungen
einen blick hinter die kulissen der
forschung zu ermöglichen
und ein großes anliegen war nach einer
psychose landesversammlung dass man ihn
explizit ist auch nicht muss was man hat
also gehabt und wie groß ist vielfalt
vom laden auf der renate zum konzipiert
die wichtige themen auf der menschheit
mit thematisieren und nicht in um
ständiges zeigen
doch die pläne für ein weiteres museum
die stoßen auf kritik
[Musik]
ich mache mir sorgen dass man jetzt
neues neues museum baut wofür ich dem
fluss 9 ist armin hast du wohl muss
jetzt eigentlich russ gewisse hätte ich
bin jedoch nicht ganz sicher und mini
sorge ich wirklich das noch auf die
andere die fliegerei darunter leidet
will wenn man so eine lüftung hat den
ist klar und die gilt und was ist aber
mit all denen andere kleinere tätig sind
die regel einfach
die fdp rechnet jetzt schon mit einem
referendum
es gibt so viel kritische stimmen der
stadt am projekt das sie feste fußballs
lassen kann
basel wird sich entscheiden müssen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sammeln forschen bewahren das waren
lange schlüsselbegriffe für die museen
doch in basel eine zukunft haben als
museumsstadt braucht es mehr aus immer
größere häuser was es jetzt braucht das
ist eine klare vision
nächste woche fragen wir ob alle kunst
die in einem museum steht einen anspruch
auf ewigkeit hat wäre diese frage mit
nein zu beantworten werden hier in basel
etwa auch gleich einige probleme gelöst
lang gleich jetzt folgt doch und zeigt
was ein bauer in kenia mit der
weltklimakonferenz zu tun hat kommen sie
gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
street los
[Musik]